Catherine McPhee we welcome you good to
see you Kelly
hello Mrs Foster so you two never plan
to do an album together no so how did
this come about and I'm wondering what
it's like working with David because you
know he can be very blunt he can be very
tough he can be very intimidating to a
lot of people what was it like for you
knowing him the way you do well I met
him when I was a contestant on American
Idol 17 years ago so I only knew him as
David Foster the producer never like as
a guy might end up dating and marrying
but uh I my first experience with him
one of my first experiences was being in
the recording studio uh he produced My
First Single when I came off the show so
when I go back into the studio with him
it's actually like where we feel most
natural like it's it's I I just have
such an immense amount of respect for
him so it's the only time I don't talk
that
people always tell the truth yes when it
comes to music about whatever is going
on so what happens when the two of you
disagree on something something anything
musicality what how does that work
um because you've got opinions too I
totally have opinions not a little mouse
burger no I was I was saying like as a
married couple I make my opinions maybe
a little bit more known but I do it's
not that I don't trust my instincts yes
I do make my opinions known but most of
the time I generally agree with the
things that he thinks about musically
and um he's like a genius I mean he's
like a musical genius yeah he is and so
even if I disagree I am you know I'm
sort of humble with my disagreement you
know because knowing I could be wrong
can we can we talk about uh something
else you're making in addition to music
jewelry yes I mean how long what what
story are you wearing today Catherine
McPhee thank you so you've launched your
own line we just launched today
um the website went live it's so crazy
because obviously singing and acting
performing was like my first love that I
knew I was good at but I've always had
this passion for jewelry I used to lay
in bed on Friday nights with my my mom
like we would watch all the jewelry
channels and I always fantasized about
like being the person up there selling
jewelry talking about jewelry like at
the home shopping like uh yeah wow yes I
always loved that idea
um and obviously that format has changed
like where you can literally just go
into your own social media account and
be that person right you can talk about
your pieces and things that you love so
um it happened like about a year and a
half ago when my son was born and I got
connected with a friend and it was so
crazy because I talked about in my head
wanting to create a line but never
actually did it and it just I think it
was like manifested in my head and and
what was the line you wanted to create
yeah when you were fantasizing about it
what did you want your jewelry to be
yeah yeah yeah I I um I had a particular
piece that I'm not wearing today but
that it's one necklace that looks like
two necklaces because I always felt like
I know I'm obsessed with spending hours
in the the mirror layering pieces but
most women don't have time to do that
um don't want to do that um but they
still like jewelry so there's a couple
pieces that we've created that are a
double chain that looks like you're
wearing two pieces so then when you add
another piece it looks like you're
wearing three pieces so that's sort of
my
um my inspiration behind it was that I
wanted to make it like a little bit
simpler for people to layer things I
love that and um yeah so because if
people come up to me all the time and
say oh my God like I love how you
layered it and I'm like well that's
because I spent three hours in the
mirror like but you don't have to you
don't have to so I mean we're obviously
growing and I'm gonna continue to grow
but that's my motivation is just trying
to make it like more simple and fun for
people because men and women we have a
unisex chain as well and can I talk to
you about your your son because David
yes yes because David had all daughters
and then the two of you had a baby boy
yes who's also he appears to have some
kind of musical something because I saw
pictures of him the other day yeah he's
obsessed with drumming and it's really
like people come up like whoa my gosh
she's going to be an amazing drummer and
we're like okay let's all just put the
you know the brakes on but I will say
that um it is very interesting to watch
him be so obsessed with it and David
just said something to me the other day
he says you know I just thought of
something when I was a little kid I I'm
now remembering like I used to get in
trouble all the time my dad would send
me to my room because I would not stop
banging and drumming on stuff because he
always had this and so he goes I wonder
if that's like a similar thing that
Rennie has so we'll see like he's
literally only 20 months old so we're
not putting on I've never started to um
I love the name right he's a great I
love the name Randy too yeah thank you
congratulations congratulations on it
all and I have to say you know Catherine
and David and I were in the studio
because we're doing a series about
things you wanted to try these and they
helped me with music what are you trying
to try again we're trying to sing what
you know it's a segment coming up
we'll talk about it later all right
thank you Catherine thank you for having
me congratulations thank you Christmas
songs is on sale November 25th right
around Thanksgiving and cats kmf jewelry
line goes on sale today